bruno daroux bonjour on continue à
décrypter ensemble ce qui se passe sur
le terrain l'ukraine et la russie aux
dernières nouvelles ont échoué à
s'entendre sur cette question
d'évacuation de civils c'est loin d'être
le seul point de discorde à aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait on arrive à un moment où
plus avec visiblement aujourd'hui donc
une grande offensive vous l'avez dit de
l'armée russe qui pilonne en plusieurs
points du territoire
marioupol le siège se poursuit dans le
dernier réduit où il ya quand même une
forte résistance des soldats ukrainien
mais où cent mille civils sur le
programme alimentaire mondial sont quand
même menacé de famine on peut dire que
les sujets de discorde ne manquent pas
et d'ailleurs volodymyr zelensky affirmé
que vladimir poutine voulait détruire le
dombass et sur marioupol estime que la
chute de marioupol en fait signifierait
donc ce sera plus qu'un point de
discorde signifierait tout simplement la
fin des tractations c'est à dire qu'il
n'y aurait plus de pourparlers entre
délégations russe et ukrainienne donc il
n'y aurait même plus d'espoir d'une
solution politique ou diplomatique à ce
conflit même si cet espoir était quand
même assez faible il y avait quand même
ces rencontres et le fait même que les
deux parties continuent à se parler
était malgré tout porteur d'un petit peu
d'espoir en tout cas là les ukrainiens
10 la chute de barrio paul pour nous en
fait c'est un peu comme une ligne rouge
à partir de là on discute plus un mot
peut-être aussi de cette invitation qui
ne nous aura pas échappé invitation à
emmanuel macron de vladimir zelensky à
venir constater le génocide c'est une
invitation à double tranchant pour ça
c'est à français oui alors c'est une
invitation qui a pas vraiment été
lancées de manière formelle 1 les
ukrainiens par exemple indique aussi
qu'il faudra bien que joe biden viennent
aussi à kiev que ce serait
symboliquement très fort mais alors la
la maison blanche a déjà fait savoir que
pour des questions de sécurité il en
était absolument hors de question la
l'invitation lancée à emmanuel macron
bon d'abord on peut s'interroger sur le
timing évidemment on est à six jours du
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle et puis le président
hélène ce qui dit moi je voudrais bien
convié emmanuel macron a constaté le
génocide commis par l'armée russe or on
sait qu emmanuel macron lui ce terme de
génocide il souhaite ne pas l'utiliser
alors certes encore une fois à quelques
jours du deuxième tour de la
présidentielle
si emmanuel macron est là bas ça ferait
de la belle image ça fera un beau coup
de com comme on dit mais attention aussi
à ne pas se laisser emprisonner entre
guillemets par la communication très
agressive du président hélène ski ça
peut se comprendre il est dans une
situation d'urgence mais il emploie donc
des termes très forts dans lesquels
emmanuel macron aurait des difficultés à
se faire enfermer parce qu'après ça
coûterait aussi définitivement le canal
de discussion avec vladimir poutine
autant vous dire je pense que en ce
moment même à l'elysée on réfléchit très
sérieusement et avec beaucoup de minutie
à la réponse que va donner ou pas
emmanuel macron parce qu'il ya d'un côté
l'avantagé effectivement d'un gain sans
doute politique avant le deuxième tour
et puis de l'autre tous les obstacles
que je viens d'énumérer